information révélée par le canard
enchaîné également par le parisien la
cour des comptes a mis sévèrement en
cause la gestion de l'agencé française
de lutte contre le sida
cet après midi son nouveau directeur a
tenu à répondre point par point à ces
critiques
reportage marque maisonneuve jean
corneille faire en sorte que change un
certain nombre de comportements humains
officiellement c'est la mission de
l'agencé française de lutte contre le
sida
et ce n'est pas franchement réussi
d'après la cour des comptes en résumé
c'est la gabegie économique jeu des
chaises musicales quatre directeurs en
trois ans pour un salaire annuel de 560
mille francs beaucoup plus que celui
prévu pour la fonction par le ministère
du budget
recours excessif à une publicité
télévisée peu convaincant neuf cent
cinquante mille francs dépensés pour
qu'un personnage séropositifs
apparaissent dans une série télé d'une
chaîne privée et ne parlons pas des
100000 préservatif acheté par l' agence
totalement inutilisable puisqu'ils
n'étaient pas aux normes françaises à
lagence le nouveau directeur n'est pas
démesurément inquiet rapport de la cour
des comptes qui
signale quelques péchés de jeunesse
d'été de ses deux premières années de
fonctionnement c'est-à-dire des années
90 80 john savini minimise il remplit
son rôle reste la brochure toute récente
à usage des dentistes détruite parce que
discriminatoires coût 120 mille francs
une goutte d'eau dans les 170 millions
de francs du budget 93
enfin toujours actuelle l'absence
d'information destinés aux toxicomanes
ou aux immigrés remarque la cour des
comptes
la svls est un organisme à but non
lucratif un organisme d'état et
l'obligation de résultat n'est peut-être
pas encore entré dans les moeurs de
cette association